randa kassis bonsoir merci d'être avec
nous sur rt france alors on le disait
selon la turquie au moins 150 soldats de
l'armée syrienne aurait été neutralisé
par l'armée turque
quelle valeur apportée à ces
déclarations il est vrai que le
président turc erdogan va continuer
toutes façons d'abord pas que compte n'y
est un son au sens et à l'intérieur de
la syrie mais aussi d' à continuer à
armer les rebelles en syrie qu en fait
qu'il se trouve dans la province d'idleb
et de l'est pas et réciproque ça va être
aussi la russie qui va soutenir le
régime syrien
en espérant bien sûr de lutter contre
les terroristes mais bien sûr pour le
régime syrien s'est pas que les
terroristes mais c'est aussi ce qu'ils
veulent c'est la reprise de la province
toutes les box pour avoir le contrôle
sur le sur l'ensemble du territoire
syrien
alors après comment ça va être c'est une
escalade et de toute façon pour moi je
les c'était vraiment prévisible de tout
cela la corde sotchi je peux te dire et
c'est une déclaration au fait c'est
plutôt sais même pas s'il est en état de
léthargie c'est la mort de cet accord là
il y aura il y aura je vois pas comment
les deux pays la russie et la turquie
vont continuer à faire semblant d'avoir
une vraie alliance une collaboration sur
le territoire syrien
car dire en vérité il n'ya pas ça
n'existe pas cette collaboration
pourquoi parce que les intérêts de ceux
des deux pays sont différents il ya un
dissensions sur pas mal de points sur le
processus politique sur sûre pour
définir d'abord qui sont les terroristes
la turquie ne considère pas les
islamistes radicaux comme les
terroristes que c'est pas le cas pour la
russie alors il ya vraiment un vrai des
sanctions moi je crois que l'alliance
qui a été fait il ya quelques temps
c'était une alliance tout simplement me
certes une alliance de survie est ce que
cette alliance va continuer à vrai dire
ou même historiquement si on voit
l'histoire entre la russie et à l'époque
notamment aux ottomans c'était de façon
il y avait toujours une histoire qui
était pleine de guerre et de haine entre
les deux est historiquement je crois que
ça dessine 6 2
les relations dans le futur proche
entre ces deux pays cette attaque
turquie est une réponse à une attaque
présumée de damas dans laquelle cinq
militaires turcs présents dans un poste
d'observation auraient péri à lille peut
être rappeler nous pourquoi l'armée
turque est elle toujours présente en
syrie sion aujourd'hui à vrai dire déjà
c'était une grosse erreur pour moi
d'accepter l'offensive turque dans le
territoire syrien dans le nord pour je
parle bien sûr dans le nord et ça
c'était la première erreur deuxième
erreur il m il fallait pas aussi accepté
que le régir g régine reprenait quelques
reprenait quelques endroits quelques
villes clés dans le nord est de toute
façon
malheureusement il n'y a pas de
processus on voit très bien qu'il n'ya
pas de processus politique le comité ce
qu'on appelle le comité constitutionnel
syrien toute façon c'est un comité qui
est vouée à l'échec
depuis très longtemps gelé déjà dit
depuis pas mal de temps et rien qui est
étonnante façon aurait lieu pas de
processus les intérêts ne sont pas les
mêmes
la turquie veut rester en série au moins
elle veut préserver préserver son armée
ou aussi ses mercenaires syrien qui
travaillent pour elles dans le nord de
la syrie ce qui va pas fonctionner le
régime aussi il veut avoir le contrôle
qui ne comprend pas jusqu'à aujourd'hui
qu'il ya une nécessité vraiment de faire
pour
de de travailler sérieusement sur un
processus politique raisonnable et
réaliste
alors je vois pas comment on va on va
sortir on arrivera à sortir de tout de
ce cadeau l'onu malheureusement vous
voyez très bien que l'onu est très
faible mais dassin toute façon il ne
peut rien faire et peut faire peut-être
l'humanitaire come back to norvégien un
bon norvégien ne faire que ça ne peut
faire que ça
à vrai dire peut-être été aussi prendre
quelques sacs de riz pour pour les
distribuer aux réfugiés comme main comme
bernard kouchner l'a fait dans le passé
alors malheureusement c'est ça la
situation avec l'onu il n'y aura rien de
tout on aurait vraiment on a cru d'avoir
touché le fond avec ban ki moon et à
aider mistura mais on a tellement
creuser encore et encore parce que on
souhaitait à trouver de pétrole mais à
la place on a trouvé un but et res et
pedersen en vagues à 6 de son côté pour
bien comprendre quel est l'objectif de
l'armée syrienne dans la région d'idleb
aujourd'hui le comme je les dis le
régime syrien il va avoir le contrôle
façon sur l'ensemble de territoire c'est
rien pourquoi parce qu'il ne souhaite
pas avoir un procès un processus
politique en serre et pour lui c'est
toujours la solution il est il et il est
il et jusqu'aujourd'hui il croit que la
solution militaire est la seule solution
et ils se croient vainqueur et c'est ça
le problème les dents un dans un état de
d'esprit schizophrène je peux l'appeler
comme d'ailleurs le cas de notre
position qu'on l'appelle snc a de la
coalition syrienne où les autres de le
comité où le ce qu'on appelle le comité
des négociations
ils sont tous tous tous ces gens là ils
sont toujours dans le même esprit qui
sont déconnectés de la réalité
et chacun et croire les autres qui
croient que à led avec l'est de la
turquie et l'arabie saoudite
ils peuvent s'imposer pour avoir quelque
chose ou revenir en série pour avoir le
pouvoir le régime aussi crois que avec
une solution militaire
il arrivera à avoir gardé le contrôle et
après bien sûr il souhaite la levée des
sanctions économiques et c'est
impossible n'aura pas de levée des
sanctions économiques il n'y aura pas de
reconstruction en syrie alors pour moi
toute façon le tout ça va durer tout ça
va durer que même pour pas mal de temps
et la russie ne pourra rien faire
malheureusement en tous les cas est ce
qu'il ya un dialogue entre damas ankara
sur les opérations menées dans la région
d'idlib
oui ils ont essayé à l'aide de la russie
mais est ce que vraiment c'était
efficace moi je crois pas parce que déjà
il n'est pas d'entente entre la russie
et la turquie
comme je les dis il ya pas mal de
dissension d'abord il faut définir qui
sont les terroristes
quand je les dis erdogan considèrent
même les islamistes radicaux ne sont pas
des terroristes les autres considèrent
que même celui qui a porté qui porte une
arme ou qui souhaiteraient même pas
porter une arme même un opposant
politique qui souhaitent avoir de
changement en syrie et à voir ce
processus politique est un terroriste
alors je vois pas comment les deux pays
où lou je veux dire le régime syrien et
le gouvernement turc pour pourrait se
mettre d'accord sur des points communs
alors une dernière question une
délégation russe se trouvait à ankara
pour des pourparlers visant à trouver
une solution aux affrontements à idlib
après ce nouvel échange d'hostilité s'il
est confirmé est ce que ces pourparlers
risquent d'être remises en cause
c'est une remise en cause avant
d'adhérer en sais pas ce qui s'est passé
ça veut dire ma compte il n'y a pas un
un des mots clairs les
communiqué qui est clair ça veut dire
que personne façon les deux côtés ne
sont pas mis d'accord
comme je les dis ils vont essayer de
faire semblant et de sauver la face
c'est à dire de garder cette alliance au
minimum mais peut-être après quelques
temps toute façon il y aura même pas
cette alliance et les relations vont
redevenir comme avant c'est à dire en
2015 c'était en 2015 2016
et ça va être aussi l'escaladent
peut-être entre les deux pays
merci beaucoup randa kassis d'avoir
partagé votre analyse je rappelle que
vous êtes présidente de la plateforme
d'astana et auteur du livre la syrie et
le retour de la russie aux éditions des
syrtes 1